we've had a lot to say about
congresswoman Maxine Waters on this show
but somehow she keeps giving us excuses
to say even more in 2002 Watters
attended a Nation of Islam convention
what happened there not much really
except this Louis Farrakhan showed up
and shortly after celebrating waters as
quote a great congresswoman Louis
Farrakhan began praising Palestinian
suicide bombers of course and then
praised Iran for helping arm them waters
apparently wasn't bothered by this of
course not Lawrence Jones is
editor-in-chief of campus reform and he
joins us tonight it's like you can't
even believe it's real but you I don't
think I don't think it's gonna run in
the New York Times tomorrow why is that
of course it's not because with the left
they have double standards on what is
actually hateful and what's racism and
they have double standards Tucker
you know this shouldn't be surprising
about the Nation of Islam because they
have been known to rape women within the
religion they have been known to grab
the people that they dislike and people
then leave the faith just ask Malcolm X
who got assassinated because he decided
to leave the faith and so this is a
pattern with this organization but the
left has different standards on what
they feel is hateful because remember
what they teach on the college cancer's
college campuses today
Tucker is that if you're not in power
which they consider minorities not in
power then you can't be racist and this
is something that is going to go on for
a long time Tucker because no one is
standing up for free speech no one is
standing against this hateful rhetoric
we try to report it every day at the
leadership Institute's campus reform but
a lot of the mainstream media is not
covering this well what's interesting
and I should just say in the interest of
total disclosure and honesty I know some
people in the nation of islam there's
really nice guys actually but there's no
defending there i mean they are but
there's no defending their core beliefs
which are racist by definition i mean
they think that god is gonna kill all
white people so like that's racist i
would say isn't it a little patronizing
to get for the press to give maxine
waters to pass on associating with
someone like this as if it doesn't
matter they have such low expectations
for her I guess that they don't even
call her on it I mean it
that's patronizing I think well it's not
just patronizing in Tucker it would be
different if they were silent on all of
these instances on racism but but you
know when it comes to Donald Trump he
doesn't even have to say anything that's
actually racist but in their mind they
can form something that is racist and
you're told that he's vowing if you
support him then you're April person but
now you have a clear evidence of racism
and they're completely silent on that
and so it's just a bunch of hypocrisy
with the press and I think that's why
their approval rating is so low right
now with the American people because
they really don't trust the press yeah
it's higher than it deserves to be it's
like how Ted Kennedy could kill a woman
and still be a considered a great
feminist so and then there's this
picture of Obama with Farrakhan which
was hidden from public view this was
2005 so it was right before his Senate
run and it was considered too
inflammatory for the rest of us to see
and so the press hid it from us don't
you think we should have had the
opportunity to make our own judgments
about that yeah we should have had the
opportunity but the thing is tucker is
that the media around in Chicago knew
about this I mean the Nation of Islam
headquarters is in Chicago they were
known to hang up with hang out with
these elected officials the question is
not not only that they shield this photo
but why did the repress refused the
report on this when the local press as
well as the national first anybody that
worked in Chicago knew that they hung
out together but they refused to tell
the American people yeah I mean Obama
had a according to a Nation of Islam guy
we talked to add a Nation of Islam
employee or adherent working in his
Senate office in in Illinois it's like
right well no exactly
Lawrence thank you for that that was
great to see you Thanks